all right he's on his way up okay we
ready what do you want us to do why do I
have to explain everything because we're
usually not on the same
page oh
okay and to
[Applause]
you stay away from AR hey I'm your boss
why don't you uh stay away from me no
I'm going to stand where I want okay you
don't want to get on my bad side I've
seen some horrible things I own over 200
horror movies okay that's so weird just
go away no you go
away so Andy what improvements would you
make as office manager for starters I
really think we can streamline
communication around here that's a very
heavy accusation to level against
Toby wasn't accusing Toby's in charge of
human resources that would include
communication I think that to's done a
fine job right I I I really wasn't
trying to insult any why I didn't think
you were I have two relationships with
Andy I have a personal relationship and
I have a professional relationship
personally yeah I think he's a rat and I
think he's responsible for the demise of
my relationship with Aaron
professionally he broke up the happiest
couple in this office how many windows
are there in New York City what critical
thing okay comment on the spot question
asked in an interview okay uh let me
think are you counting car windows no
how far away is the
sun uh 93 million
miles is it yeah and the diameter of the
Sun is 870,000 Miles which makes it 109
times wider than the earth and 333,000
times heavier than the earth shut up
about the sun shut up about the
Sun
walk away
well I manag my department and
I've been doing that for several years
now and God I've learned a lot of life
lessons along the way your Department's
just you right yes Jim but I am not easy
to manage great um can we just what was
that we just have a lot of serious
candidates to get through today so am I
not a serious candidate
what do you want me to say I mean
there's a line of qualified people out
there we have a video CV from England
are we all just going to pretend to okay
um what are your weaknesses I don't have
any
ass ke you can't I need to talk to you
you can't be in here this is a lady's
bathro Erin Ain I respect your privacy
but that I will follow you in here every
time you go if that's what it
takes greed not cool
man I really think you should leave
someday you are going to tell our
grandchildren about how their
grandfather won you back in a women's
room can we talk about this later I have
to go okay ju just read the letter under
your windshield wiper okay it explains
everything okay do you want Gabe
well got to catch a
plane oh hey Gabe I'm sorry we we didn't
get you cake or anything we're going to
miss you oh well I'm still the
corporately as oned Branch you are not
leaving not giving me a
hug okay you know what you don't need to
make that sound I'm sorry you were just
a lot bonier than I thought you were
going to be there are plenty of people
who love touching me I'm a terrific
Huger I've been with a bunch of girls
where that's basically all they want to
do in case you can't read my my my poker
face we will be reviewing our sales
policies I I have 10 seconds to explain
them or this whole place blows up
MBA has anyone started calling you Gabe
wad yet not here
no hey I need you to get the paperwork
rolling on a new workplace relationship
for you yes for Gabe who are you seeing
that's great whom I'm seeing is Val from
down in the warehouse I'm not
technically seeing her but uh I've seen
her with the eyes and uh there was
attaction in at least one direction
ction
so you know I don't have to do paperwork
unless you're actually dating okay well
once this starts it's going to be moving
fast it's going to be hot and heavy and
I don't want a bunch of bureaucratic red
tape wrapped around my jock you know but
I mean have you talk to her yeah we had
a whole conversation about
Mondays do you know her last name yet
Toby I'm going to tell you her last name
tomorrow because she's going to be
screaming it tonight she's going to be
screaming her own last name hey watch it
good luck Gabe Gabe did Aaron ever
tell you that she loves you no no no no
no no no no no no no no no she wouldn't
even let me say it it was adorable she'd
plug her ears and scream her heart out
can you stop talking because every word
out of your mouth is like the squawk of
an ugly Pelican I got a tattoo for you I
didn't ask you to get that Nike Swoosh
nobody did you did that for you just do
it you were the it that I was just doing
uh you play oh I like to create
soundscapes Imagine One instant of a
song expanded to be the size of the
Universe I can't even do
that this one's called Earth rise on the
moon that's so
beautiful what kind of music are you
into Peter uh I like all kinds of music
Gabe really all kinds so you like songs
of hate written by the White to the Klux
Clan are you even hearing this he didn't
even say that he's not a very
sophisticated man I mean he can't use
chopsticks so do I need to say anything
else Aon I've been to Japan I know how
to use chopsticks so well come back one
night I what is that supposed to be is
that I don't want you to sh I wasted two
years of my life on you you realize that
right I just want to be real clear that
Chopsticks is not the measure of a man I
am as smooth as
a
man my delts are
blasted I wish they had a chart for how
much protein powder to scoop for a 180
lb man with no fat protein powder huh
you cut it with water why don't you just
take
estrogen there you go boys see how Papa
takes care of you m
I remember when people thought biceps
were all that they'd Flex them all night
at the Disco tech oh I bet you think
it's all about core huh yeah cor is
critical there are four tenants of
Pilates that I live my life by one lanin
two elongate listen guys I think we all
want to know the same thing right who's
the strongest there's only one way to
solve
that THL
contest all right here we go everybody
May the manliest man win go
[Applause]
Feast on this
Louis I love the bird burn this where I
live come on Gabe you can't handle his
hamstrings you're getting hypnotized
speed
one here this for your elbows for your
elbows quick phone call for you guys
keep going eight N9 hello 10 we got it
very funny Jim yeah Jim way to mock us
for perfecting our bodies everyone
conference room
now all
right did someone say girl
talk sometimes I wonder if I have
ovaries in my scrotum because I am great
at girl talk have you guys been watching
any good Korean soap operas I'm pretty
into he Jung Cinderella girl although I
definitely fast forward through the
young T story lines do you think I'd
like that or is it important to have an
Asian fetish uh I think you're going to
need to have an Asian fetish yeah it'll
be upsetting if you don't everyone
please relax I think you're going to
like this surprise
guest happy birthday to game oh get out
Skeleton
Man
very funny everyone who wrote captions
under my
doodle I'm not even kidding they're
pretty good which one in particular yeah
which one well the first one has a
surprise Factor I'm a suck suck sucky
saber
booah no no no no no but uh I suppose
the second one is the better written
line you suppose what's it say I'm
supposed to be wearing red gloves but my
color cartridge portal got jammed again
okay uh no no no no no gloves one for
you cool thanks and one for you oh
thanks and oh you missed your
head there you go Phill s
[Music]
fast
okay